welcome to this video or motzko crush I
cannot pronounce that impossible okay we
gotta have been only I think we had some
balloon is some in earlier games and
let's see this line really got me some
good results the night e to g 39 with
the game quite comparable to the Z mesh
variation okay he just puts it on near
five they very often even earlier start
start with them start with the h5 ideas
and no 4f for this is the idea going for
this all out attack one idea not the
only idea but here it looks justified
now he would like to complete his
development with Bishop d7 Burgess
blunders appears it's not so easy to
make a move ready that somehow helps
black
hmm
yeah maybe b5 just just tossing a pawn
and fought some counter play
it looks very desperate yeah if you have
to do that maybe some things something's
not quite right so um what is going on I
can take it i mean i should take once
anyway and now yeah if I don't take
before heads f4 is an alternative of
course have fun but Bishop Teague's I
mean if it goes Bishop d7 which looks
kind of normal or is there another move
Bishop age three this kind of business
maybe no no so I wanted to go back this
was my idea now F form is the threat his
his Knight has no square maybe he has to
create a square for the night with c
form yeah he did that f for now yeah did
the check but still therefore he will
play 93 no question
takes takes f 5 i'm going to play a prep
move just going to cover b2 and wait for
a moment with any f for action I can
also really just play I mean you know
Bishop e3 to d4f for this kind of thing
keeping total control black really is
just a pawn down I don't need to play
any any rush to text or whatever I can
even play King age 1 and then think
about f4 at the right moment he's just
he's really just sitting down and then
you cannot move any of those pieces
empty the night can just ditch another
porn on d3 by 93 but no other minor
piece can do anything meaningful yeah
yeah I can think about we rooting Bishop
to d1 for Bishop c2 sometimes this is an
idea you know what I'm going to do this
push up to d4 I like that this is just a
super square for this piece so f1 still
93 coming
yeah i'm just going to do this improving
moves and see what what is big idea is
queen bee 744 rugby aid
ya see for was hanging him so can I do F
for now f 1 93 takes see takes then e 5
breaking through yeah c'mon I would have
liked to even get rook and a king h1 in
but this really now should work between
before though Queen before might be
possible but I have have Queen f4 Queen
f2 ozone no well if he has to move the
night then Wow
yeah okay if i move the Queen to f2 then
what d 2 possible and if i take here
take hero crook we'll check him we'll
take g3 hangs at the end so a queen move
looks good like we have to hmm just
feels like there should be something
even better
they are Queen Queen f2 and f 2 ad to
aft after ad to I thought just look
group t1 maybe all the night bag I can
also move the night bag like this I mean
he can still cannot move their 69 it
feels a bit awkward to let this pawn
exist on the tool but I don't see how he
does anything with it
okay so wants to take on g5 can I go
Knight c3 here first and then it can
take the five okay so I'm going to take
the piece it's definitely not a mistake
Knight c3 here intending look T 1 rook
give one yeah rocky one is good look be
to this nightie for with that double
attack on rook and queen ant is without
this resign Bishop on h8 add the modern
benoni sometimes looked like looks
terrible if there's something going
wrong it looks like an opening that just
loses that's not the case but it is a
tightrope you walk you walk a very thin
line all the time um here it's very
difficult to play this position here um
as normal moves do hail the computer
suggests Bishop g7 with already with a
substantial edge for wide you know I'm
not sure that he should allow something
so that that he did allow easily like
here I mean something like h5 is really
useful and trying to push age for this
kind of this kind of move I mean this is
this fields already very comfortable
Bishop age 6 I mean he cannot take on
age 6 this looks looks awful so back and
um I Bishop g5 is also move I don't know
I really don't don't know what black you
should do here I'm not have been only
player i cannot i don't think that this
is like lost or anything but i have a
hard time to give black some some advice
this already wreaked off of desperation
this b5 move and it's really not working
but draws it was terrible it was which
was difficult to play and TM many many
options but ultimately I like what I did
playing it a bit slower not trying to to
kill him immediately just getting all
the things on better squares here maybe
this wasn't even the best young when f4
is a debatable move definitely because i
have have really all the time am i don't
need to rush anything i can also just
play something purely positional i liked
it like here roop here night over to e3
and pick up see for this is this is
probably very convincing I don't need to
play with their form yeah the thing is
that here look before was in fact
possible after the capture I'm winning
but look before I did not think about
this but it's it is given by the engine
why exactly I know it now Adam it is
some adjusting his over its evaluation
and why this is also good him and but
this is kind of kind of kind of shaky
and very unlikely that I would have
found all the move I mean this is
looking this is looking like a very
weird line purely tactical yeah the way
it went it is really just losing her all
night f5s is a winning shot I didn't see
that one ya tinks check
yeah okay I can I III agree has this
probably Whitney with this hopefully
also okay I didn't spoil anything here
okay well thanks for watching